nats phillies
at the bank elise have beaten the
nationals four of the first six so far
this year zach wheeler he's been
dominating the last couple months and
actually from may 6th what a day he
leads major league baseball
in strikeouts he's second in era and
fourth in
whip swing and a miss
he saw one fastball that was the first
pitch and then nothing else after that
load equalizer so you want to turn on my
fastball soto
six for 27 against wheeler there he goes
and soto turns on one
turner easily to third
and that soft line drive was a foot from
being an inning ending double play juan
just got it over the leap of brad miller
had a big spot early for josh bell
bell jammed and he drops it in front of
bryce harper
that's have the line moving here trey
who walked with one out touch his own
josh bell rbi number 28
25 and 8 with an at score first this
year but he has had first inning issues
so
that's nine earned runs of the 24. he's
given up all year
and gomes rips it for a base hit to left
soto coming around third
the throw is late
from mccutchen and the nationals three
consecutive singles to go up to nothing
one two pitch
and a fastball at the knees a strike
three calls
out to center field o'doodle is there
and he makes the catch and the inning
he's finally over 36 pitches
for zach wheeler scherzer faces the
phillies for the 23rd time he's 12-4
with a 262.
that is right in there and he wasn't
looking for a fastball you wouldn't
think a guy would be blown away by such
a high fast hall but reese hoskins
cannot get to max's heater up
got him
took the air out of that one
no chance at 86. oh the nightmare
continues there's strikeout number 12.
nasty
he gets the 86 slider to strike out
hoskins and rio muto
and max scherzer strikes out the site we
go to the bottom of the second and bryce
harper will lead things off for the
phillies
that one is drilled deep to right field
forget
about it that's a long home run for
bryce harper and the phillies are on the
board
it's now a 2-1 game
ninth home run for harper it is his
500th career extra base hit
and that's a long one
yeah that was a little cheapy right
there and
you know it's basically the same pitch
to josh bell but bryce got it to it
quicker than josh bell did on that fifth
down and end
that's right where jan gomez wanted it a
beauty
strikeout number four first out second
inning
max holds on to that off speed pitch too
long so in a pair of walks after the
homer
phillies have first and second one out
follows it up with the high heat so in
two innings
max has five strikeouts
hey juan soto says you give me left
field i'll take it he's two for two
heard some noise that means the runner's
going
and not able to pick it cleanly was
miller as rio muto short hopped it and
juan soto steals it back
that ball has hit hard up the middle in
fact
the good news is not hard enough
soto scores easily
as the ball got through and then just
kind of died on the outfield grass
and jan gomes has a two hit two rbi
night three one nationals here's castro
breaking ball and castro turns on it
off the wall gomes into third and
starlin castro now six of his last eight
hits have been for two bases
and that gets josh harrison
who's hit by a pitch for the tenth time
that thing just chased him and he had
nowhere to go
broken back ground ball to third ball
will just take it to the third base back
side is retired
oh one pitch that one's out toward right
center field on the run of soto he's not
gonna get there and it's off the top of
the scoreboard
and reese will hustle his way to second
with his 16th double of the year
it's his first hit against max scherzer
had to swing
then mccutchen stumbled out of the box
and castro might have taken a peek and
he dropped it
for his eighth error of the year
fastball up
down on strikes for max scherzer number
seven
they gonna check max here
in the middle of an inning
[Applause]
is going to get mad at him this is in
the middle of an inning after you struck
a guy out basically by having
girardi come out there
just insinuating that hey
there's no way this guy is being this
good naturally something has to be going
on one and two to jankowski
racing over
castro
well when you try to upset
what max scherzer is doing when he's
starting a baseball game you are asking
for trouble
got him on the hands
josh bell chasing it
oh right in the webbing of his first
baseman's mitt nice running catch and
you know the philly's faithful are
yelling at him as he's headed towards
the stands
struck him out on a fast ball up and in
max scherzer as the inning ended gazing
over toward the phillies dugout
didn't say anything just looked and then
joe gerardi came up and said come on
over
firing everybody up and he was ejected
from the ball game
that's the ejection from tim timmons
40th ejection for joe
now max says look hey i'm clean
look at me my hands my ball cap i'm
clean he's like here you can have it you
can check for yourself
josh harrison rips it basic
upstairs runner going another short
throw and that time a great pick by brad
miller to get the tag down
josh harrison's not sold on it
let's see if josh gets that left flipper
in there before the tag is applied and i
think he is correct
he is safe
[Applause]
bouncer back to the box ranger suarez is
cool as a cat
flips it over to first he gets a couple
ground balls back to himself to take
care of the nationals here in the sixth
he'll get his uh glove checked out
louise hoskins the hitter
and a high fly ball forget about it it
is a long home run for reese huskins and
he's just made this a one-run game
well after a bunch of fastballs randy
tried to throw another one this one
though just got middle in
a little up and reese just got that foot
back quick and just destroyed this one
16 home runs 43 runs batted in
all right so now with two outs at the
bottom of the eighth and in grad hand is
the new pitcher it'll be lefty on lefty
breaks his bat and he loops it out to
left center for a hit
harper takes a big turn around first
the two out single
oh he's going to get him looking and
mccutcheon knows he's been had
tossed the bat away he knew it was
strike three and brad hand gets out of
it in the eighth inning
now the 2-2 pitch coming the ball
and a line drive out toward left center
field that'll be in for a base hit it's
going to go to the warning track row
blaze will cut it off and balm speeds to
second the tying run is at second base
[Music]
and it hit him
[Applause]
runners
[Applause]
so they can
do that
this is hard to tell
something happening that fast if there
was a redirect
crew chief
he gets first base he's hit by the pitch
ready here's the pitch
a little dribbling over to shortstop
turner coming in tries to bare hand he
can't make the play the bases are loaded
and burling keeps the inning and the
hopes alive
and the breaking ball hit to left
not at all deep harrison he's got it
trey is
obviously taking the worst of that
collision
and hopefully trey maybe just got the
win knocked out of him but
ground ball trey turner the throw
the nets win it
nerves of steal
for the net's closer brad hand who does
it again